[Musique]
tout le monde
va qure pack d'eau pour ma famille on
est 6 dans la maison et pour la
distribution d'eau je trouve c'est il
est assez bien pour les gens parce que
il y en a ils ont pas la possibilité
d'avoir d'aller acheter des PAP d'eau et
toutp moi je trouve c'est assez bien
pour d'autres familles beaucoup de
familles à Mayot
ici
[Musique]
ça fait presque un mois tous les tous
les dates je viens je reçois les deux
pqus ou trois pqus ça dépend
parlez tu donne la sécurité sociale et
votre il y a pas de critère faut résider
sur la commune où on doit se présenter
là mamouou il faut résider sur la
commune de mamouou et comme la commune
de mamouou est de 8 village il faut être
de ce village là aujourd'hui on est à
Cavani il faut la population qu'on va
recevoir faut qu'il soit
exceptionnellement de Cavani on a les
agents de CC de la mairie de Mamoudou
qui pilote la mairie de Mamoudou qui
pilote l'AC
CCAS qui est le moteur et après on a des
associations on a des bénévoles qui nous
aident à que tout se passe
bien